hey guys this is andrew from
trendsenses.com so very quickly for
those who haven't watched my videos
yet i've been working as a professional
trader for the past six years in hong
kong and right now i'm doing youtube
videos
where i must talk about technical
analysis which is something that
i use every day to set up my trades and
i want to show you guys how to do it
yourself
so in today's video i want to make
another analysis on amc
let's get into it
[Music]
and yes so for those who have watched my
previous videos i was basically
so let me sum up the situation here i
did
a video here where i started to be
bullish guys
let me just quickly explain again
how i do my analysis i like to
use idiot waves this is all the drawings
that you can see on my
charts i'm gonna go through this but i
only use illiot waves in order to
draw some efficient trend lines this is
the most important thing this is
how i found my signals most of the times
and here i had this trend line
connecting this high and this high
and that gave me a breakout here i told
you guys i gave you this breakout
this was like around the 15th of april
and as usual
the breakout occurs the same way it is
broken
then re-tested so here for example the
right level to
enter this trade would have been around
9
9 20 but this is the past then
i did another videos where i basically
was
showing you guys the different scenarios
that i was seeing
with illiot waves counting and my
preferred scenario
was that actually so let me redo this
with you guys so i'm gonna show you
where we are
what is happening right now my preferred
scenario was that this
abc here this corrective phase that
lasts
between the 22nd of march and the
14th of april all this corrective phase
has been complete
once we broke this trendline here then
i had different scenarios but my
preferred one was we're making one two
and we are in the third wave
but to be in the third wave i was
expecting some strong moves
up coming very soon and i told you guys
i think during the weekend because i did
an update after friday's close that i
was expecting a very bullish
monday which actually happened and
i'm telling you again what i've said
already and then i'm gonna come to the
new stuff
i was telling you that the macd would
turn positive
just mathematically because if the price
action is not going strongly
lower and this is exactly what happened
here guys
the open was around like 10 17
gap up get 1070 sorry we're doing a nice
gap
up and immediately we went to visit
some new highs in the recent past
which created a lot of bullish momentum
the magnitude and green a lot of
investors stepped
in the game and both imc so we had those
two more days coming here so let me now
analyze the situation and give you
the new levels and tell you if yes or
not i'm still bullish so
i'm not gonna keep the suspense longer
than this of course i am bullish
because here we are exactly in my
scenario we are trading above the moving
averages
the magnitude daily is green and as you
can see here only
three days so usually you can see that
those periods they last around 10
15 days so it's not because the magnet
is green that the price action is gonna
go
higher every day it's just kind of it's
a cycle it's a bullish cycle that we're
having that we started here
uh the volumes slightly went up but it's
not massive yet for a third wave i'm
expecting more
so i'm expecting actually more moves up
to come this week
and hopefully next week as well
once again guys for our time frame the
best one to use so
you check the moving averages and you
and you see where you have support
here you can see that the 200 and 100
they are under 50 sorry they are quite
far away so they could be used as
uh support levels if the price action is
going lower
but in a third wave guys we're not going
to revisit those levels if we go there
if we break actually the 20 which is
actually a support right now
we need to ask some questions we need to
try to understand
why the price action is going lower and
are we
really in this third wave another way to
find your support levels so
here the support level is around 10 you
know 1060 and it's growing 10.70
tomorrow is going to be around 10 90 so
below 1090 careful
if you're wondering guys if we are just
in a healthy correction or if we are in
a
new move down you can use one very
efficient tool which is fibonacci
so to do that you measure so that's why
idiot wave is
is very useful as well because you need
to measure a wave so here
let me first do the idiot wave counting
so i need to go
on 30 minutes time frame because this is
accounting
daily counting and we need to find five
waves here and try to
uh guess if yes or not this move up is
finished and
here when i measure this so
one two is that a three
or is it three maybe higher to to answer
this question
try to see if you can find five waves
here and i can
so three four five
and why is this a nice three guys
just because of that look
three four five all right i have five
waves in my third wave
so i know this is a third wave if this
is a third wave
this is a first this is a fifth let me
get rid of this i'm just showing you
guys that
the third wave is clean and this is
a typical false wave then one two three
four five
here as well i can have five waves so
actually this
first cycle is complete and we are just
correcting
so now that i know that this is the
first wave
of my third wave
that is here in yellow you see this
third wave guys
this one is just the first wave and we
are just correcting this first wave
which is absolutely normal we are still
bullish here yeah and to answer even
better this question
you can measure this wave and check the
retracements guys
there is the bullish zone and the
bearish on the bullish zone is above
50 and sometimes we can go to
the 1.618 retracement level that is just
below
so here i would tell you that my
scenario is still fitting very well
as long as we stay above 1060 again you
can see that this level is giving you
here
up 1060 perfectly guys the this level is
giving you
by two different methods the moving
averages on the forest time frame
you also have the top of the third wave
here so this is support as well and you
have the 50
retracement of fibonacci so i would say
that
1060 is my strongest support on the
short term
if we break it we still have one more
chance at 10
20 right this is still possible
but let's be honest here we have already
the abc guys
okay so i'm not expecting any further
correction but the c wave can be a bit
longer all right this can happen so
maybe we could have this
so this is kind of my bearish case is
that the abc would have
would actually maybe even be like this
okay
so we need to see what is going to
happen around the 11 30 area
i want to break this area again we did
it already once which is confirming our
bullish case
but we didn't hold above on the daily
time frame
so this scenario is still on the table
then we would go to 10
20 we could still be in a bullish
development as we stay
above the 0.618 1020 so this could still
be
a typical one two
all right this could still work right
and then we go to the third wave here
this is very
possible as well so let's see 10 60 10
20
there are my support level on the short
term so i told you
that the 1130 level was very important
the reason why i said that is that i was
still
looking for a w x y correction you know
something like this
and this is now off the table guys
because here we broke
this high that was created by the b wave
on the fourth time frame it was broken
perfectly re-tested you can see i'm
gonna show you guys how this acted as
support as well
but this scenario is now definitely
off the table all right it's not
possible by following illiad waves
rules by the way for those who are
interested just click on the link in the
description of this video and you're
going to receive a free training where i
explain everything about
illiot wave rules and how to use
those rules between them so here for
example we cannot go above the b
wave if we want to have the w x y so
this
is now off the table guys so we are left
with
our only scenario that is bullish
and here like i said the typical
situation would be
we'll just go higher right away so i'm
doing this video on
thursday morning in hong kong so you're
gonna receive it for thursday
morning in the u.s in a few hours and
i'm expecting a bullish thursday one
more thing
let me show you how we reacted well
on this level so here guys i told you 11
30 was an important level
and i think it's interesting for you
guys to notice you know
that of course this level has been spot
not only by me but by all the day
traders and maybe even long-term
investors because here
you can see that we first arrived we got
rejected you see under 30 minutes time
frame
we got rejected then we blew right
through it
really tested it here we go here retest
again
consolidate break out again on the
downside
and right now i don't expect this
on the daily like i said it was broken
okay but guys as i always tell you
for a breakout to be confirmed you need
to have two consecutive
candles trading below the breakout level
so here i have one
and i don't expect to have a second one
let's see i might be wrong here but
you know everything is going in the same
direction for me
one more thing i want to show you guys
is about the divergences i show you how
i spot
that there was there would be a reversal
coming you know i showed you guys that i
had a bullish divergence
here price action going lower macd going
higher all right
so this was a bullish divergence that i
had
i show you guys this and here i'm
checking
if i don't have any bearish divergence
it's very you know it's to control if
your
scenario is actually correct if you see
a
bearish divergence then you need to
worry you need to ask yourself are you
actually thinking about everything
properly
so here to take the divergences as usual
guys
we connect the recent laws for example
here
and we see if the macd is going lower
here it's not going over so i don't have
a hidden buddhist divergence so no
buddhist divergence but i was telling
you guys that we are looking for
some bearish divergences so then i
connect
the higher highs i try to see if the
market is actually
doing lower highs with the macd but
it's not the case here as well you see
high highs
let me show you quickly what are the
different divergences all right
so i was looking for some uh bearish
regular divergence so market going
higher and the macd going lower you know
making
higher highs and the maxi making lower
highs
i didn't find any of this on the hourly
timeframe which is confronting me
in the fact that the bullish case is
valid now this was the hidden divergence
that i had
last week on the aolitum frame which was
uh telling me that the buddhist case is
my preferred scenario
and we're still having this hidden
divergence on the long term let me show
you again
on the long term we're still having here
guys the
bullish hidden divergence market so let
me go on the daily
market making higher lows with the maxi
making
lower lows here between 0.2 and minus
0.2
roughly between feb and afro in the two
months period
market making higher lows the macd
making lower
lows this is a hidden bullish divergence
which was also telling me that the
bullish case is the most likely
one so i think i've told you guys
everything i'm gonna do
another video very soon where i'm gonna
analyze the news i'm gonna analyze the
option market as well
see if the volatility is giving me any
information see if the positions
of the open interest on this option
market
is growing in the right direction what
is the synthetic short
so if you guys enjoyed this video please
don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button so you're gonna be
the first to know when i upload anything
new and stay close to show i see you
guys